Das habe ich so noch nie erlebt! Da jauchzen
Teslafahrer hemmunglos in die Kamera!
Und dasNetz wird geflutet mit Videos aus Auto-Cockpits.
Elon Musk hat seinen nächsten Coup gelandet. Die
erste Beta für volles Autonomes Fahren
ist veröffentlicht worden und die ersten
fahrer posten Videos, die das System Hands
on oder besser Hands off ziegen. Warum jetzt
eine neue Epoche anbricht. Clixoom Science
& Future - hier gibt es drei Mal pro Woche
spannende Science-Video. Abonniert den Kanal und
aktiviert die Glocke; nur so verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich Willkommen. Teslas haben in
jeder Hinsicht ein absolut revolutionäres
Fahrzeugkonzept. Teslas sind nicht nur einfach
Elektroautos, sondern fahrende Innovationsträger.
Was die Konkurrenz tatsächlich in Angst und
Schrecken versetzt ist die Computertechnik
in einem Tesla. Statt 80 bis 100 Steuergeräte
für jede einzelne Funktion wie Klimaanlage,
ESP, Fensterheber, Scheibenwischer, ABS
usw. haben Teslas nur ein einziges, einen
Hochleistungscomputer, der alles zentral steuert.
Das ist so revolutionär, dass der Kabelbaum in
einem Tesla demnächst von einem Roboter verlegt
werden kann. Die Kabel ist dann nicht mehr wie
im Model S drei Kilometer lang, sondern 100
Meter. In einem VW, BMW oder Mercedes wäre das
undenkbar. Die Beschleunigung der Fahrzeuge ist
atemberaubend. Selbst in der einfachsten Version
beschleunigt das Model 3 in 5,6 Sekunden auf 100
km/h. Die Fahrzeuge verfügen über 8 Kameras um den
Verkehr zu beobachten und darauf zu reagieren.
Und in Verbindung mit dem Hochleistungsrechner
wird bisher für Unmögliches wohl möglich werden,
wie sich jetzt in diesen Tagen herausstellt. Und
nicht zuletzt hat Tesla das große Problem des
Elektroantriebs gelöst, was die konventionellen
Autobauer noch nicht mal erkannt hatten: Das
Batteriemanagement. Tesla hat es erfunden. Tesla
hat sich als einziger Autohersteller Gedanken dazu
gemacht, wie Batterien behandelt werden müssen,
damit sie in dem Temperaturbereich arbeiten, den
die Batteriehersteller vorgegeben haben. Tesla
baute als erstes ein Kühl- und Heizsystem in die
Wagen ein und konnte so zum ersten Mal zwei Dinge
gewährleisten: Die Reichweite sinkt bei Kälte
nicht mehr dramatisch bis zur Unbrauchbarkeit
und zweitens halten die Batterien durch diese
Behandlung entscheidend länger, nämlich verglichen
mit einem Verbrenner mehrere Autoleben. Und mit
all diesen Innovationen sind Teslas mehr als
Autos. Sie sind Technologieträger und ein Blick
in die Zukunft. Sie stiften eine neue Generation
und werden unsere Sicht auf die Welt verändern.
Und nicht nur in der Realität, wenn irgendein
Sportwagen auf der Autobahn dicht auffährt und
man im Tesla das Gaspedal antippt, wird man sich
wundern warum die anderen Autos den Rückwärtsgang
einlegen. Ein Tesla ist tatsächlich so, als würde
man in einem Paralleluniversum aufwachen. Und
jetzt wird dieses Gefühl noch stärker. Denn was
Tesla da als UPdate over the air gerade zugänglich
macht ist schlicht und ergreifend spektakulär.
Das ist wirklich ein wenig skurril. Weil
zwei Teslafahrer offensichtlich Angst haben
die Geheimhaltungsvereinbarung mit Tesla
zu brechen, zeigen sie nicht das System,
sondern ihre Reaktion darauf. Und die ist
wirklich lustig. Ich fahre ja selbst ein
Model S und ich kann mir sehr genau vorstellen,
was da gerade passiert. Plötzlich hat das Auto
vollkommen neue Fähigkeiten und kann Dinge,
die niemand vorher für möglich gehalten hat,
insbesondere nicht die Fachwelt. Wer heute einen
Tesla kauft und die Option “Volles Potenzial für
autonomes Fahren” mitbestellt, der bekommt
ein Fahrzeug, dass bereits über einige sehr
bemerkenswerte Fähigkeiten verfügt. Zwar muss in
Deutschland der Fahrende jederzeit in der Lage
sein die Kontrolle zu übernehmen, aber ein solches
Elektroauto kann nahezu selbstständig auf der
Autobahn von A nach B fahren. Sprich: Lediglich
Spurwechsel müssen von Hand bestätigt werden,
das Fahrzeug führt sie dann aber selbstständig
aus. In der Stadt hält ein so ausgestatteter
Tesla selbstständig an Ampeln und fährt nach
Bestätigung wieder los. Allerdings können die
Wagen weder selbstständig abbiegen noch die Spur
wechseln und so weiter. Das Erlebnis ist also noch
sehr eingeschränkt. Mit dem Update 2020.40.8.10
hat sich das jetzt grundlegend geändert. Bisher
lief diese Software auf den Fahrzeugen im
Hintergrund im sogenannten Shadowmodus. D.h.
sie griff überhaupt nicht ein und war auch im
Cockpit gar nicht zugänglich, aber lernte bei
jedem gefahrenen Kilometer von abertausenden
Teslas. Denn das ist der Quantenvorsprung von
Tesla: Mit hunderttausenden Autos sammelt der
Energiekonzern ständig aber und aber Millionen
Daten um seine Systeme zu trainieren. Und in der
Entwicklungsabteilung sitzen hunderte Fachleute,
die nichts anderes machen als die Videos
zu labeln. Sprich: Wenn die Fahrenden ihr
Einverständnis gegeben haben, werden die Aufnahmen
der acht Kameras zu Tesla übermittelt und dort
analysiert. Die künstliche Intelligenz hinter
dem System muss lernen was was ist. Ist das ein
Fahrrad, das ganz normal gefahren wird,ist es auf
einem Gepäckträger montiert, wird es geschoben
usw. Jede Möglichkeit muss die Software lernen
und wenn sie dann jeweils gut vorbereitet ist,
dann lernt sie von selbst weiter. Und jetzt hat
sie offenbar so viel gelernt, dass Elon Musk sie
freigegeben hat. Noch vor wenigen Wochen hat sie
auf seiner eigenen Pendlerstrecke noch drei Fehler
gemacht, bei denen Musk eingreifen musste. Aber
diese Situationen hat sie jetzt gemeistert. Und
jetzt soll das System weiter lernen. Nur sehr
wenige Tesla konnten die Version 2020.40.8.10
installieren. In den einschlägigen Verzeichnissen,
in denen aufgelistet ist, wer wann welche Software
installiert hat ist sogar nur ein Model 3 zu
finden Stand 23.10.2020 12 Uhr mittags. Es
dürften aber schon bereits wohl einige dutzend
sein. Allerdings kommt das Update rund ein Jahr
später, als es Elon Musk angekündigt hatte. Der
Grund: Die ursprüngliche Software funktionierte
nicht. Für Skeptiker ein Grund Musks Ansage
anzuzweifeln, dass das System überhaupt jemals
funktionieren würde. Denn alle Konkurrenten setzen
auf zahlreiche Sensoren unter anderem Lidar, einem
System zur Abstands und Geschwindigkeitsmessung
mit Laserstrahlen. Musk hält das für überflüssigen
Quatsch und ist davon überzeugt lediglich mit
Kamera und Radar die Umgebung der Fahrzeuge
ausreichend zu erfassen. Und der Rollout dieser
Betaversion scheint ihm recht zu geben. Sie
basiert jetzt auf der dreidimensionalen Erfassung
aller Objekte und wurde komplett neu geschrieben,
um den Autopilot endlich zum Funktionieren zu
bringen. Die Fahrenden sind begeistert und von
großen Fehlern, wie den Phantombremsungen beim
bisherigen System wird auch nicht berichtet.
Denn das war ein großes Problem der bisherigen
Software, das inzwischen behoben worden sein
soll. Aktiviert man den Tempomat, dann wird
auch immer die Abstandsfunktion des Models S
aktiviert. Dabei wählt man den Abstand manuell
am Hebel für den Tempomat und den Autopiloten.
Wenn man den Hebel einmal zu sich zieht, dann
wird der Tempomat aktiviert und beim Doppelzug
aktiviert sich der Autopilot, der zum einen die
Spur hält und zum anderen nach Betätigen des
Blinkers automatisch die Spur wechselt und wenn
man die automatische Navigation gewählt hat auch
selbstständig Ausfahrten inklusive Blinken und
Abfahren nimmt. Dann muss man selbst nach einigen
hundert Metern das Steuer übernehmen. Soweit
so gut. Doch zuweilen wird das System komplett
außerplanmäßig selbst aktiv und bremst ziemlich
stark. Das ist keine Vollbremsung, aber eine sehr
starke Verzögerung, mit der im Zweifel Fahrzeuge
hinter einem nicht rechnen. Auffahrunfälle drohen.
Das kann im fließenden Verkehr passieren
oder auf komplett freier Bahn vor einem,
wo sich überhaupt kein Hindernis befindet. Also
genau der seltene Fall, in dem derjenige haftet,
der vorne bremst. Das wäre dann dumm gebremst. Das
scheint also vom Tisch zu sein und die Teslati,
wie die Teslafahrerinnen und -fahrer auch genannt
werden sind überaus begeistert. Das ist auch
kein Wunder: Was da jetzt dokumentiert wird, ist
absolut mindblowing. Zum einen zeigt das Display
jetzt eine vollkomen neue Ansicht. Musk hatte ja
ein 4D System angekündigt. Das System soll nicht
nur den Raum erfassen, sondern eben auch zeitliche
Abläufe, um abzuschätzen wann welches Objekt in
der Zukunft wo sein könnte, um Kollisionen zu
vermeiden. Aus den acht Kamerawinkeln wird die
Situation aus der Vogelperspektive dreidimensional
erfasst und somit ein beeindruckendes Abbild der
realen Situation generiert. Jetzt sind plötzlich
vollkommen neue Dinge möglich. Das System kann
das Fahrzeug jetzt in einen Kreisverkehr steuern
und wieder heraus. Mit der alten Software war das
unmöglich. Das konnte sie einfach nicht. Endlich
kann links in den Verkehr zügig abgebogen werden.
Das System benötigt keine Bestätigung vom Fahrer
mehr, sondern vollkommen autonom den gesamten
Verkehr erfassen und darauf reagieren. Es weicht
Fahrzeugen aus, hält an Ampeln und fährt ohne
zutun los. Undsoweiterundsofort. Mal wieder
hat Elon Musk alle Skeptiker Lügen gestraft
und Unmögliches möglich gemacht. Allerdings warnt
Tesla jetzt noch massiver vor der Verwendung als
schon beim bisherigen System, weil diese Version
noch unkalkuliert reagieren kann, was nur durch
aufmerksames Fahren verhindert werden kann. So
die Releasenotes. Das Risiko wird als extrem hoch
eingeschätzt, dass sich Fahrende schon bei dieser
Betaversion zu hundert Prozent darauf verlassen,
was tödlich sein kann. Aber als erprobter
Teslafahrer oder als Fahrerin kennt man das ja
vom alten System. Man musste auf Phantombremsungen
vorbereitet sein und sie schnell abbrechen.
In Baustellen folgt das Fahrzeug gerne mal den
falschen Markierungen. Wem sein Leben lieb ist,
der weiß, dass man solchen Systemen NOCH nicht
einhundert Prozent vertrauen kann und es auch
nicht darf. In Deutschland soll autonomes Fahren
ab 2022 erlaubt sein. Allerdings muss bis dahin
auch ein tempolimit her, denn Fahrzeuge, die
von hinten mit 250 ran brettern kann kein System
erfassen. Auf jeden Fall hat Musk damit den Weg zu
den Tesla Robotaxis frei gemacht. Jede und jeder
kann in der Zukunft seinen Tesla als Robotaxi
betreiben und damit Geld verdienen. Die Software
wird dann so erweitert, dass man zum einen zum
Beispiel Familienmitglieder hinzufügen kann,
die dann mit ihrem Smartphone die Fahrzeuge
öffnen können. Aber man kann das Fahrzeug auch,
wenn man es nicht braucht, als Robotaxi
betreiben und jeder kann sich dann von
einem privaten Tesla chauffieren lassen. Und
die Besitzer und Besitzerinnen verdienen dabei
auch noch Geld mit ihrem Tesla. Das Taxinetzwerk
inklusive Flotte ist bei einem Tesla schon mit
eingebaut. Und mit dem heutigen Tag wird diese
Perspektive jetzt schon viel konkreter. Und noch
mehr revolutionäre Technik gibt es bei Tesla: Die
Batterie-Revolution - Tesla Batterie kommt 2022!
Anklicken, anschauen und abonnieren. Diesen Kanal.
Clixoom Science & Future! Bis dann bleibt dran!